a
OF THEIR CAUCUSES.
SARA?
>> LAUREN FOX, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ALL OF THAT THERE ON CAPITOL
HILL.
>>> ALSO MORE TROUBLE, LEGAL ;
a
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP.
HIS ATTORNEY REPRESENTING HIM IN
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT'S PROBE ;
a
AT MAR-A-LAGO TOOK HIGHLY
DETAILED NOTES ABOUT THEIR
CONVERSATION, A PARTICULAR NOTE;
a
DEPARTMENT'S EFFORTS TO RECOVER
THOSE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS OR A;
a
.
THE NOTES ARE NOW FROM TRUMP'S
LAWYER, EVAN CORCORAN, IN THE
HANDS OF SPECIAL COUNSEL JACK
SMITH.
ALSO, SOURCES TELL CNN
PROSECUTORS SUBPOENAED THE TRUM;
a
ORGANIZATION FOR INFORMATION
ABOUT BUSINESS DEALS WITH ;
a
INTERESTED IN THE TYPES OF ;
FROM THE FORMER PRESIDENT AT ;
a
MAR-A-LAGO.
THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION HAS JUST;
a
.
LET ME READ IT TO YOU IN PART,
QUOTE, WE MADE A STRICT PLEDGE ;
a
IN OFFICE.
A COMMITMENT THAT THE COMPANY
FULLY COMPLIED WITH.
JOINING US NOW, CNN POLITICAL ;
a
JEREMY SALON.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU BOTH.
JEREMY, I'LL START WITH YOU.
IT'S NORMAL THAT AN ATTORNEY, A
GOOD ATTORNEY, EVAN CORCORAN, ;
a
.
BUT THE FACT THAT JACK SMITH HAS
THEM NOW AFTER SUCH A FIGHT TO ;
a
>> WELL, ON ITS FACE PEOPLE CAN
THINK OR ASSUME THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS JUST SAYING, HEY, ;
a
WANT TO FIGHT THIS.
THIS IS A REASONABLE
CONVERSATION TO HAVE.
>> IT MIKE, RIGHT?
WE SHOULD GIVE HIM THAT.;
a
>> CERTAINLY SHOULD, BUT AT THE
SAME TIME, THAT'S A DIRECT LOOK
INTO HIS INTENT AND HIS ;
a
DOCUMENTS THAT ARE CLASSIFIED.;
THESE ARE DOCUMENTS I HAVE TO ;
a
>> THAT I SHOULDN'T HAVE. ;
.
BUT NONETHELESS, I'M GOING TO ;
a
FIND A WAY TO CHALLENGE IT.;
SOON THEN THERE'S LEGAL MEANS T;
a
.
IT KIND OF DEFEATS THE ARGUMENT
THAT I DIDN'T KNOW.
>> THAT'S SO INTERESTING. ;
a
>> I WANTED TO ASK ABOUT ;
ATTORNEY/CLIENT PRIVILEGE.;
a
I COULDN'T HELP MYSELF THE NOTE;
OF IN THE HANDS OF JACK SMITH.;
a
CAN THEY USE THAT IF THEY DEEM,
LOOK, WE GOT THESE.
BUT WE HAVE THEM?
>> YOU CERTAINLY RAISE IT AS A ;
a
DEFENSE
BUT AS WE KNOW, ATTORNEY/CLIENT
PRIVILEGES DEFEATED IF WHAT IS
GOING ON IS AN ATTEMPT TO EITHE;
a
INVESTIGATION OF A CRIME.
AND IN THAT CASE HE'S RIGHT BACK
WHERE HE STARTED.
SO, YOU KNOW, WHAT'S REALLY
GOING TO MATTER IS WHAT ELSE ;
a
WENT ON IN THAT CONVERSATION.
IT'S ONE THING TO LEARN THAT
DONALD TRUMP ASKED CAN WE SORT ;
a
OF FIGHT AGAINST THE SUBPOENA.;
BUT WHAT ELSE WAS SAID?
WHAT DID THE ATTORNEYS THEN TELL
HIM?
HOW DID HE REACT TO THAT?
THAT'S WHERE IT'S GOING TO START
TO GET STICKY, I THINK. ;
a
>> THAT'S REALLY INTERESTING.;
THAT'S THE DEFENSE NIXON TRIED ;
a
S
.
AND WHEN WE'RE INVESTIGATING A ;
a
CRIME -- LET'S TURN THE TABLE
HERE ON WHAT E. JEAN CARROLL IS;
a
SEXUAL BATTERY AND DEFENSE CASE;
AGAINST THE FORMER PRESIDENT.;
a
ON GOING CASE TO ADD MORE,
JEREMY, OF TRUMP'S WORDS IN THE;
a
THAT.
DO YOU THINK SHE'LL BE SUCCESS
NFL.
>> AS A MATTER OF LAW, THERE'S ;
a
THAT HIS WORDS WERE MALICIOUS ;
DOWN AND CONTINUED THAT.
LET ME TAKE THAT BACK.
IT'S AMENDING THAT ON GOING ;
a
COMPLAINT.
AND IT ESTABLISHES AND CONFIRMS;
a
THAT THE PRESIDENT WAS WILLING
TO BE MALICIOUS, KNEW IT WAS AN;
a
WAS REALLY USING SOME OF THE
SAME WORDS THAT HE WAS FOUND ;
a
LIABLE FOR ALMOST MOMENTS AGO.;
RECENT POLLING ERROL, TO YOU.;
a
.
EVEN AFTER THE --
>> EVEN AFTER THE LIABILITY, TH;
a
$5 MILLION THAT HE IS TO PAY, ;
YOU'RE SEEING THESE NUMBERS ;
a
.
WHY IS THAT?
>> YEAH
ONE PART OF IT, VERY CORE THING;
a
YOU HAVE TO KEEP IN MIND, IS ;
THAT MOST PEOPLE ARE NOT PAYING
ATTENTION TO THESE THINGS.
SO IN WHATEVER CAPACITY DONALD ;
a
GETS NATIONAL EXPOSURE, IT ;
REMINDS PEOPLE, HE USED TO BE
OUR PRESIDENT, I KIND OF LIKED ;
a
THEMSELVES OUT.
DOES IT NECESSARILY MEAN THAT ;
a
THINK THAT THIS MEANS THAT HE ;
SHOULD BE PRESIDENT BECAUSE HE
JUST LOST ANOTHER CASE OR HAS
BEEN INDICTED CRIMINALLY IN NEW;
a
YORK CITY?
I DON'T THINK SO.
>> I COULDN'T HELP THIS, I GET A
LOT OF SORT OF SOLICITATION FOR;
a
MONEY FROM ALL THE PARTIES ;
>> RIGHT.
>> SO WHAT YOU SEE SOMETIMES IS;
a
THESE CASES BEING USED AS, LOOK,
THEY'RE COMING AFTER ME, PLEASE;
a
.
IT'S BEING USED AS A FUNDRAISIN;
a
>> IT IS.
I USE THE TERM FUNNY BUT THAT'S;
a
REALLY NOT APPROPRIATE.
THE ARGUMENT HAS ALWAYS BEEN TH;
a
DEEP STATE IS AFTER ME.
LOOK, THEY'RE COMING AFTER ME.
BUT, WHAT THE DEEP STATE, IT'S A
STATE OF MIND AND HIS WORDS ;
a
GETTING HIM DEEPER AND DEEPER I;
TROUBLE
ULTIMATELY THIS IS GOING TO ;
a
CATCH UP TO HIM.
HE'S GOT GEORGIA, THE CITY OF
NEW YORK.
NOW HE HAS THE FEDERAL PROBE
THAT'S BEEN ON GOING.
JUST ONE ON TOP OF THE OTHER.;
a
THE MORE HE DOES THIS, AND THE
MORE HE USES HIS WORDS WITHOUT
HIS COUNSEL AND EVIDENTLY EVEN ;
a
WITH HIS COUNSEL THE MORE HE ;
.
I WOULD NOT BE SHOCKED
ULTIMATELY IF HE DOES END UP
INCARCERATED, WHICH IS SOMETHING
I WOULD NOT HAVE THOUGHT MONTHS
O AGO OR --
>> WHY DO YOU THINK IT NOW?;
a
>> SO MANY DIFFERENT THINGS THAT
DEVELOPING THAT ARE REALLY ;
a
SIGNIFICANT CRIMES.
YOU'RE TAKING DOCUMENTS AND
MATERIALS THAT ARE CONFIDENTIAL;
a
E
OR CONCEALING THEM.
THERE'S AN ON GOING
YOU KNOWINGLY TAKING STEPS TO ;
a
RETRIEVING THAT PROPERTY.;
THAT JUST SORT OF FURTHERS
THE -- MY BELIEF AND I THINK ;
a
GOVERNMENT HAVE TO PROVE THEIR ;
CASE BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT ;
a
THAT THERE IS SOMETHING A
HERE.
IT'S CONTINUATION AND
CONTINUATION OF TROUBLE THAT ;
a
HE'S GETTING HIMSELF INTO WITH
HIS WORDS THAT ARE CONTRADICTOR;
a
AND HIS ACTIONS THAT ARGUABLY
SPEAK FOR HIMSELF.
IF YOU RECALL IN THE FEDERAL
MATTER THE JUDGE SAID ON ITS
FACE THERE'S CRIMINALITY.;
a
THAT'S A LOWER STANDARD. ;
>> YOU HAVE TO CONTINUE -- IT'S;
a
A LOWER STANDARD.
>> TO CONTINUE THE PROBE. ;
a
.
FRAUD EXCEPTION.
THERE'S SOMETHING HERE.
CAN'T JUST SAY WHERE THERE'S
SMOKE THERE'S FIRE, BUT